[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin cette
année c'est à dire une hache et bonjour
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
au ministre délégué chargé de
l'industrie on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par julien lécuyer
de la voix du nord bonjour julien
bonjour aux lionnes mais on commence
bien sûr une espagne harnachés par ces
annonces d'hier un d'olivier ferrand qui
tire une nouvelle fois la sonnette
d'alarmé 69 départements en alerte et l'
alerte maximale notamment dans la
métropole d'aix marseille où les bars et
restaurants fermeront samedi et ça a
provoqué la colère des élus marseillais
michel rubio la maire de marseille qui
parle d'un gouvernement déconnecté des
réalités renaud muselier le président de
la région de sud qui accuse d'olivier
rang de perdre son sang froid est-ce
qu'ils ont raison et ce qui a eu un
manque de concertation
je crois au contraire que c'est un
gouvernement très connectée aux réalités
très connectée à la santé des français
et dont le rôle est d'assumer des
décisions qui sont difficiles et on le
reconnaît c'est difficile pour protéger
les français et c'est ce que nous
faisons avec les marseillais
alors évidemment il ya des conséquences
économiques
et évidemment va les traiter bruno le
maire et alain griset annoncé déjà hier
qu ils réuniront aujourd'hui l'ensemble
de la filière pour justement
regardez comment on va les accompagner
louis restauration tous ceux qui sont
concernés par cette décision d'un point
de vue économique pour voir comment on
va les accompagner
vous savez on est dans l'action et c'est
vraiment pas le moment de polémiquer
nous traversons une crise qui ont poussé
totalement il me les i c'est ce que font
michel ribeiro line renaud muselier
je trouve un peu parce que il ya
toujours cette position de paris et de
la du territoire mais en réalité ces
décisions il faut les prendre sur la
situation telle qu'elle est et il s'agit
pas d'opposer un centre qui ne saurait
pas qu'ils seraient déconnectés enfin
c'est vraiment une espèce de deux
thématiques un petit peu dévoyé répétées
et aujourd'hui on doit faire face à la
réalité de la situation
les chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes la
situation à marseille aix n'est pas la
même que sur le reste la ministre si
vous permettez c'est vrai que les élus
locaux à la fois ne comprennent pas que
il n'y a pas eu de concertation alors
que olivier ferrand hier disait que
chaque préfet allait se mettre encore en
concertation dans les jours prochains
justement pour adapter au niveau local
est ce qu a annoncé olivier veyron c'est
une décision c'est un coup de massue
qu'ils ont du mal gré comprendre et sur
le terrain on entend aussi des
témoignages qui disent on autorise
finalement les gens à aller travailler
on les autorise à prendre les transports
en commun et à être serrés les uns
contre les autres dans la dans les bus
mais finalement les on n'accepte pas ce
qu'ils soient sur des sur des terrasses
est ce que vous comprenez 7,7
ces interrogations en fait sur une
terrasse ou ne portait pas votre masque
c'est une différence assez sensible gens
pour l on pourrait le décider
au moins pendant le récent rejet avec un
masque si vous y arrivez mais on ne fait
pas seulement nationaux essayez de boire
sur une avec un masque c'est ça la
grosse différence et je crois qu'il faut
pas tomber dans ce type de polémiques de
petites polémiques
c'est magnifique il ya des enjeux
énormes il ya des gens que lorsque nous
savons que dans les transports en commun
et au travail on porte un masque on peut
respecter des gestes barrières de
manière beaucoup plus simple que
lorsqu'on est dans la convivialité et
que te dire ça qui ait du sens commun
est de faire je dirais attention à la
santé des français et de regarder les
statistiques et malheureusement les
statistiques elles sont cruels et elle
donne la réalité c'est prendre nos
responsabilité de gouvernants c'est
prendre nos responsabilités face aux
français y compris quand la décision est
difficile et alors qu'elle est laide
allez vous reconduire pour la aider le
secteur de la restauration ça c'est de
ce dont vont discuter bruno le maire et
un à griser avec l'ensemble du secteur
vous savez qu'à chaque fois qu'il y a eu
des décisions qui empêchait des
professionnels de travailler
nous avons été au rendez vous le fonds
de solidarité c'est plus de 6 milliards
d'euros porté par l'état
6 milliards d'euros qui ont accompagné
plus d'un million d'entreprises
donc nous serons encore au rendez vous
bien entendu est ce que cette ces
mesures annoncées cette remontée en de
l'épidémie avec les chiffres sont là ça
va mettre un coup d'arrêt au timide
redémarrage de l'industrie française je
crois que là on n'est pas sur la même
type d'économie
ça va
les décisions qui ont été annoncées elle
impacte le secteur de l'hôtellerie de la
restauration
ce n'est pas le secteur de l'industrie
pour le moment l'important pour le
secteur de l'industrie
c'est le redémarrage mondial c'est le
redémarrage de l'ensemble des économies
notamment des économies européennes
c'est qu'on soit globalement relance est
donc aujourd'hui la grèce décidé aux
grandes dents associant beaux jours de
l'épidémie
oui mais l'industrie est un des maillons
de cette industrie qui est en train de
l'industrie est en train de redémarrer
et sa dynamique est assez indépendante
de celle d'autres secteurs qui sont
celles de services tournés vers la
convivialité donc je crois qu'il faut
pas tout mélanger
ça ne veut pas dire que la situation
dans l'industrie soit simple l'important
dans l'industrie c'est la façon dont les
carnets de commandes vont se recharger
et dont on va passer un trou d'air dans
certains secteurs on le sait dans
l'aéronautique
on a un trou d'air de plusieurs années
pas de plusieurs mois parce que l'arrêt
de l'aviation commerciale empêche de
commander des avions qui empêche de
faire tourner des chaînes aéronautique
aujourd'hui alors on imagine que le
gouvernement se prépare à gérer une
seconde vague qui pourrait être forte
on ne le sait pas pour le moment est ce
que vous mettez déjà des entreprises
françaises en alerte sur ce qui a manqué
lors de la première vague des masques
dégel est ce que vous avez déjà un
travail avec ses industries en fait nous
avons anticipé ce travail au mois de
juillet puisque moi j'ai cosigné une
recommandation pour l'ensemble des
entreprises avec olivier ferrand et avec
elisabeth bornes leur demandant de faire
un stock de 10 semaines de masques dans
les entreprises précisément pour
anticiper ce type de situation
s'agissant du gel hydroalcoolique
on est en bonne posture ya pas de
situation de tension s'agissant des
gestes barrières
aujourd'hui l'ensemble des entreprises
ont rodé leurs dispositifs
depuis le mois de mai ces dispositifs
ont eu le temps d'être appropriés par
les salariés et d'être rôdé sur le
terrain de même que les systèmes de
télétravail et donc on est plutôt en
meilleure posture qu'on ne le fut au
moins de marge en vous brutalement la
situation vous dit le matin
français rassurez vous on ne connaîtra
pas les mêmes problème qu'en mars vous
ne manquerez pas de masque pas de gel
quelques 3 de langue quelle que soit
l'ampleur de la seconde vague
je rappelle que sur les masques nous
étions 1,3 million de masques produits
en france sur les masques chirurgicaux
et ffp2 nous sommes aujourd'hui au delà
de 50 millions par semaine par semaine
et nous serons à 100 millions à la fin
d'année et s'agissant des masques
textile j'étais hier soir avec la
filière textile qui attend les commandes
et qui vraiment fait vous un appel aux
entreprises pour privilégier leurs
masques filtrants filtrant delà de 90 %
c'est-à-dire vraiment des performances
exceptionnelles de protection des
salariés
en dix ans nous produisons français
c'est plus écologique
mais sur les entrepreneurs équipez-vous
chasse que les entreprises ne font pas
assez appel à ces entreprises françaises
tout à fait mais aujourd'hui il ya une
petite déception la filière textile
parce que on continue à préférer des
masques à usage unique
c'est plus cher et moins écologique et
même si on produit des masques en france
en volume
on peut plus produire de masquer textile
en france est ce qu'il n'ya pas un sujet
madame ministre également sur les haies
sur les gants alors c'est peut-être
moins grand public mais ça intéressera
énormément le personnel de santé nous a
fait part d'une augmentation parfois par
quatre des duperies déléguant à la
fabrication au point que madame brigitte
bourguignon la ministre déléguée à
l'autonomie se poser la question de
savoir s'il ne fallait pas intervenir
sur ce sur ses prix voire même compensé
par l'état le surcoût qui est avait
appliqué aux établissements est-ce que
là il n'y a pas un sujet à traiter
rapidement alors ça je laisserais
brigitte bourguignon adressé sujet au
niveau des ehpad 1 sur la prise en
charge du grand âge les gants c'est une
production qui est international pour
une raison toute simple c'est que la
matière première elle n'est pas produite
en france puisque c'est de l'hévéa et
qu'il faut un certain climat pour
pouvoir faire pousser ses arbres là
c'est un dérivé du caoutchouc donc
effectivement vous avez une
concentration du marché des gants dans
des pays asiatiques et bloquer les prix
n'auraient pas d'impact puisque ce sont
des productions qui sont importés et
même si nous avons un fabricant ou des
projets de fabrication de gants il ya là
matière première dont on a besoin
ça sera ensuite chacun dans son je
dirais périmètre d'apprécier si la
charge pour payer tel ou tel bien
suppose une intervention d'état encore
une fois l'état a été au rendez vous
systématiquement à chaque fois qu'il
fallait accompagner les collectivités
locales les entreprises les hôpitaux les
ehpad pour compenser des difficultés
financières je crois qu'il faut savoir
le reconnaître aujourd'hui et il l'a
fait très rapidement puisque dès le 15
avril nous avions déployé l'ensemble des
dispositifs
allez on va passer à ces plans sociaux
qui menacent malheureusement plusieurs
entreprises on commence par bridgestone
julien oui évidemment c'est un dossier
qui nous tient à coeur évidemment la
voix la voix du nord plus de 800 emplois
qui sont qui sont menacés un
investissement de biens du bridgestone
de l'entreprise bridgestone dans la
transformation de l'usiné ce que vous y
croyez encore
je vais regarder les chiffres j'ai
regardé très précisément la situation de
bari la situation de bari c'est un
accord plus que c'est l'exemple est
donné ses 12 usines italiennes qui
devait être fermé en 2013 puis en 2015
dans lequel bridgestone a accepté
finalement de faire un investissement à
deux conditions
la première condition c'est un
co-investissement des autorités
publiques locales et nationales à
hauteur de 12 millions d'euros ont parlé
d'un investissement total de 40 millions
d'euros et la deuxième condition c'est
une baisse des salaires de l'ordre de de
mémoire 40%
la première condition si elle devait
arriver sur la table
je crois qu'il n'y aurait aucune
hésitation ni de la part de la région ni
de la part des élus locaux ni la part de
l'état pour accompagner la
transformation d'une usine qui la
rendrait durable pendant des années la
deuxième condition est une condition
drastique et qui ne correspond
probablement pas aux attentes des
salariés
donc ce que nous allons faire
aujourd'hui c'est d'étudier très
simplement les différents scénarios des
scénarios de maintien d'une activité
autour du pneu soit de fabrication soit
dans la chaîne recyclage par exemple
est-ce que ça a un sens sur cette usine
et regarder des alternatives mais moi ce
que j'ai demandé à bridgestone
ceux qui l'ont accepté c'est
effectivement de remettre d'abord de
travailler à livre ouvert de remettre à
plat les scénarios et de regarder des
scénarios dans lequel bridgestone est
partie prenante et pas seulement aux
bridgestone laisserait un chèque sur la
table pour s'en aller
je pense que c'est la responsabilité de
bridgestone de travailler sur ces sujets
là vous savez qu'on a un accord de
méthode qui a été signé en 48 heures ce
qui est plutôt bon signe dans lequel
bridgestone a repris toutes les demandes
des organisations syndicales en terme
justement de temps libéré pour les
représentants des salariés en termes de
temps de négociations nous avons cinq
mois maintenant pour construire un
projet pour ce site
est ce que vous êtes comme le président
des hauts de france xavier bertrand a
qualifié ce set ce projet de fermeture
comme n'assassine après donc un
assassinat prémédité
je crois que je veux pas être dans
affective
moi je suis dans la construction
aujourd'hui on n'a pas le choix que de
trouver une solution pour ce site est
une solution pour les 8 163 salariés et
c'est ça qui me motive
je vais pas distribuer les bons et les
mauvais points si on veut avancer il
faut trouver une solution ne pas perdre
de temps sur le passé on sait ce que le
passé et c'est une entreprise qui a
perdu progressivement de la
compétitivité
il ya eu une tentative l'année dernière
pour trouver un accord de
restructuration et de réinvestissement
probablement que cet accord était à
mi-chemin n'allait pas suffisamment noie
dans le réinvestissement
elle est trop loin dans certains
éléments et il n'a pas été il n'a pas
fait l'objet d'un soutien ma part des
salariés pour trouver un projet il faut
que les salariés suivent et c'est ce qui
va nous motiver
la question est est naïve mais est-ce
que depuis votre réunion de lundi il ya
déjà des choses qui ont avancé sur ce
dossier depuis lundi on est mardi d'eau
donc aujourd'hui on a effectivement
nommer un cabinet
un conseil tiers qui va expertiser
l'ensemble des hypothèses
nous travaillons avec bridgestone sur
les éléments qu'ils peuvent nous
communiquer mais à ce stade on ne
construit pas une solution industrielle
en 48 heures ce ne serait pas sérieux ça
voudrait dire qu'elle existait déjà si
c'était le cas donc nous nous sommes
dans la phase de travail
ça va prendre du temps toutes ces
solutions je pense à hambach je pense à
borg warner qui sont des situations
équivalente c'est-à-dire de menaces de
fermeture avec des recherches de
solution ça se construit sur plusieurs
mois vous avez déjà une crosse au visage
de dieu - donc boire varner il ya deux
repreneurs possibles en barre il ya un
repreneur possible aujourd'hui
bridgestone
on est au tout début de l'histoire
presque avec bridgestone avec la
direction brych all vous avait déjà une
prochaine date de réunion
bien sûr nous avons une première date de
réunion qui est prévu d'ici deux à trois
semaines donc dans la semaine de mémoire
du 5 octobre
il faut caler exactement pour que tout
le monde puisse être autour de la table
et il y a un rendez vous important avec
les organisations syndicales à partir du
1er octobre
elisabeth bornes travail en temps masqué
pour refaire tout l'évaluation des
compétences des personnes qui
travaillent à bridgestone dont vous
veillez on ne chôme pas dans les jours
qui viennent
alors on parle beaucoup de bridgestone
c'est vrai ces dernières heures mais
malheureusement il n'y a pas que cette
entreprise qui est concerné il ya
beaucoup de plans sociaux on va
peut-être les voir à l'image est ce que
vous vous préparez à une vague de plans
sociaux est ce que vous arrivez à
chiffrer ce qui va se passer dans les
prochains mois alors je vais reprendre
les chiffres d'elisabeth bornes qui est
ministre du travail et qui est à la
manoeuvre sur ces sujets là elle indiqué
qu'il y avait aujourd'hui déposer un peu
plus de 300 plans sociaux pour un peu
plus de cinquante mille salariés déposé
ce n'est pas forcément la photo finish
derrière chacun de ces plans sociaux il
ya chacun de ces plans sociaux il y à
une négociation et cette négociation
avec les outils qui a mis en place
l'état vise à réduire autant que
possible
l'addition pour les travailleurs
français je veux redire ici qu'il ya un
dispositif d'activité partielle de
longue durée qui n'est sans égal
au niveau européen et lorsque vous
regardez la suppression massive
d'emplois au niveau mondial vous
apercevez que la france aujourd'hui
payer une addition j'ai encore une fois
je dis pas que nous sommes dans une
période d'un dynamisme échevelé mais
l'addition que nous payons a été très
fortement réduite parce que l'état s'est
impliqué et parce que l'état a mis sur
la table des dispositifs extrêmement
puissant pour limiter la perte de
compétences et pour protéger les salades
c'est ce que vous valorisez excusez moi
à l'heure actuelle ces activités temps
partiel de longue durée et puis les
accords de compétitivité finalement est
ce que vous dites aussi aux gens il faut
il est peut-être temps d'accepter
parfois des baisses de salaires pour
poursuivre l'activité
alors les accords de compétitivité en
règle générale ils vont s'attacher pas
baisser le salaire principal mais à
revoir les primes annexes et tout un
ensemble d'éléments qui peuvent peser
effectivement ponctuellement sur la
lente reprise
ces accords de compétitivité oui ça peut
être des bonnes portes de sortie il est
important qu'ils soient équilibrés il
est important qu'ils soient l'objet d'un
dialogue social construit et de qualité
au sein de l'entreprise
il est important aussi qui prévoit des
mécanismes ou si tout le monde s'en sort
bien tout le monde s'y retrouve à la fin
c'est à dire ce qu'on appelle le partage
de la valeur
nous nous poussons à ce qu'il y ait un
est-ce qu'on développe encore plus les
accords d'intéressement les accords de
participation et l'actionnariat salarié
autant de dispositifs qui font que quand
l'entreprise traverse un moment
difficile tout le monde se serre les
coudes
mais quand elle rebondit tout le monde
en profite
et ça c'est important il ya d'autres
emplois qui sont menacés chez nokia
notamment iliad l'un de nos
téléspectateurs qui a sauté vous poser
une question à ce sujet on va regarder
[Musique]
alors il s'appelle bernard aigon ils
vous demandent que compte faire le
gouvernement face au désengagement de
nokia au plan social annoncé cette
suppression de 1200 33 postes en
recherche et développement sur la singer
dont 402 ingénieurs à lannion est ce que
vous êtes pour la promotion du
savoir-faire français développé depuis
60 ans est ce qu'il vous demande tout à
fait et d'ailleurs nous y travaillons de
très près pour vous donner une idée je
voyais lundi le directeur général frans
d'ericsson pour lui parler de la
situation
mardi il y avait une réunion
interministérielle pour regarder ce que
les services de l'état pouvait faire
puisque vous savez que la direction
générale de l'armement et non s'ils ont
des recrutements dans les domaines de
cybersécurité et correspondant aux
correspond aux compétences des
ingénieurs concernés chez nokia
mercredi nous avons eu un contact avec
qualcomm et j'ai vu la patronne france
d'orange
donc tous les jours il se passe quelque
chose sur le dossier de nokia nous
sommes évidemment en contact avec la
direction de nokia pour également
discuté d'une possible réduction du plan
qui serait le corollaire d'un
réinvestissement dans certaines dents
certains éléments de recherche et
développement puisque possibles
réductions juste ça veut dire quoi on
rappelle qu' à 8 131 postes qui sont
menacés dans l'essonne et ses 400 de
postes qui sont menacées ne donnerai pas
de chiffres
je fais pas de leurs promesses on attend
d'avoir les écoliers sur dix est tout à
fait mais à ce stade c'est les salariés
qui auront l'information la première et
c'est quand même ce qu'on leur doit
il me semble c'est pas dans les journaux
qu'on apprend les les plans qui vous
concerne
et par ailleurs il est également
important d'avoir ce contact mais
équipes ont un contact toutes les
semaines avec le représentant des
salariés et nokia qui selon les
syndicats reçus de 180 millions dad
entre 2016 et 2019 au titre du cse et ça
repose la question des contreparties
il ya hervé marseille qui est le
président du groupe centriste ici au
sénat qui annonce sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr que lors de
l'examen du plan de relance il va faire
des propositions fortes pour qu'il y ait
des contreparties à ces aides aux
entreprises parce que vous êtes prêts à
le suivre sur ces questions alors
plusieurs
choses d'abord le cic ça n'existe plus
en france mais et c'est ce gouvernement
qu'il agit en crise
voilà et je pense que il faut se
départir de cette idée que il ya
systématiquement dz donc le cic eux on
n'en parle plus
la deuxième chose c'est effectivement
nous on est prêts on a déjà travaillé
sur des contreparties
vous avez des prêts garantis par l'état
qui sont assorties de contreparties de
décarbonation on n'a pas attendu que ce
débat soit sur la place publique tous
les investissements qui sont soutenus
par exemple dans l'industrie moi je les
accompagne un certain nombre
d'entreprises les 2400 projet
aujourd'hui qui sont déposés pour de la
modernisation industrielle pour de la
décarbonation pour de la relocalisation
de 1400 projets c'est juste gigantesque
dans le monde industriel je rappelle
qu'il ya trente trois mille pme
industrielles 1000 entreprises de taille
intermédiaire donc c'est pour vous
donner la maille est bien derrière
chacun de ces projets il ya une
localisation d'investissement est un
projet très clairement établie on ne va
pas financer n'importe quoi allait il
nous reste peu de temps mais un sujet
qui dont vous occuper aussi ce sont les
jouets genre et une charte qui a été
signée julien oui en effet vous avez
signé cette charte pour lutter contre
les stéréotypes les jouets alors c'est
vrai que encore un peu tôt dans la
saison mais on commence à on va
commencer à s'en préoccuper
qu'est ce que vous voulez par la montrer
alors voilà c'est la charte que dont
c'est la première année
anniversaire pourquoi cette charte mon
sujet c'est pas de savoir si les jeux
sont roses ou son bleu mon sujet c'est
que les petites filles puissent se
projeter des leurs cinq ans 6 ans 7 ans
dans des univers qu'ils ne soient pas
fermées
lorsqu'on pense à la construction
lorsqu'on pense à des jeux un petit peu
on va dire scientifique ou même dans des
pros des professions qu'ils soient
qu'ils sont présumés réservé aux petits
aux petits garçons une barbie
spationautes
c'est une façon de nourrir l'imaginaire
des petites filles donc vraiment notre
enjeu c'est de partir du constat que
depuis 40 ans il ya eu une évolution ou
les jouets se sont devenus de plus en
plus genre et que l'on réserve un
certain type de jouet qui développe
plutôt des compétences verbal chez les
filles et des jouets qui développe pour
les garçons plutôt des compétences de
construction et de créativité et que ça
enferme les uns et les autres dans des
univers qui derrière vont avoir une
implication sur leurs choix
d'orientation et de carrière pourquoi
les petites filles qui sont bons en
maths font systématiquement des sciences
du vivant et pas des sciences dures je
pose la question est aujourd'hui notre
enjeu c'est que toutes les petites
filles et tous les petits garçons et
toutes les orientations professionnelles
ouverte et que ce ne soit pas nos
projections qui influe leur carrière et
des chiffres 1 en france il n'y a pas
plus de 30% de femmes dans l'industrie
et il ya 17 % de femmes dans les
fonctions exécutives c'est-à-dire de
direction eh ben c'est un handicap pour
notre compétitivité
les dernières questions en espagnol une
échelle et elle est politique est ce que
vous serez candidate aux régionales
moi je les dis les régionales c'est
l'économie le développement économique
et le rééquilibrage sur les territoires
c'est évidemment des sujets qui me
passionnent
lidl france c'est mon territoire où j'ai
grandi et je suis évidemment disponible
pour être candidate mais le sujet
aujourd'hui c'est pas de savoir qui est
candidat le sujet c'est d'avoir une vie
où je pense que la majorité
présidentielle a une vision distinctive
d'autres voix des républicains ou de la
gauche que nous devons porter cette
vision que nous devons apporter ensemble
chacun en prenant notre risque est que
derrière nous devons faire
collectivement cette campagne julien
bonnet question c'est parce que il y à
il ya quand même on a l'impression que
ça occupe beaucoup l'esprit en tout cas
cette tête de liste on parle de
gabriella table de jean michel blanquer
d'elisabeth bornes de de vous est ce que
vous vous en avez à 100% en vie par
exemple puisque les autres est-ce que
vous en avais plus envie que les autres
non mais je pense que moi je me pose pas
cette question de cette manière je me
pose plutôt la question de caisse qui va
faire qu'on vous portera le mieux le
projet vous en avez envie très envie
comme comment est votre avis là-dessus
dites le nous alors je vais le redire il
ya des conditions de réussite à cette
campagne et ses conditions de réussite
c'est la clé pour en avoir envie c'est à
dire qu'il faut avoir un projet qui est
vraiment de l'ambition et une majorité
présidentielle qu'ils soient réunies
derrière où chacun prend son risque
d'affecter présidentielle unie ce n'est
pas vraiment le cas en ce moment
eh ben c'est exactement la maison
commune mais ça peut être compliqué
faisons là c'est le moment
merci beaucoup merci en espagne et une
hache et d'avoir été avec nous merci
julien lécuyer on va regarder ensemble
avec la une de la voix du nord
aujourd'hui consacré bien sûr à cette
crise sanitaire métropole lilloise
alerte renforcée merci d'avoir été avec
nous ce matin parce que tito club le
territoire la mutuelle nationale
territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux
vous présente le club des territoires
angie acteurs engagés dans la transition
zéro carbone des régions vous présente
le club des territoires
[Musique]